mais plus que ça bientôt discuter
écouter jour deux se trouvent sur un air
cas survive et bond un survival tout
fraîchement sortie où on est donc en jeu
alors var doit créer notre bonhomme
alors notre bonhomme
personne ne dit jamais ça d'habitude
c'est très étrange est-ce qu'on le fait
vraiment très leahy les ultras les mon
gars j'ai fait un géant il sort du cadre
carrément il y avait un bug votre
septiers quoi ah là c'est parti on joue
une kawa ça tout bref je lance le jeu
hein je connais absolument rien on va
découvrir en ce sens est parti alors là
c'est un jeu dans lequel on croit ya des
dinosaures on doit survivre et j'ai même
vu qu'on peut monter sur un dinosaure
voilà comme si c'est un cheval
finalement 1
attends je peux l'attaqué bah on va déjà
mourir il est quoi il est le bel20
moyens et je te fais des petites eu des
petits coups de poing dans les fesses
aulas je te défonce moi oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] élèves un dino honnête - zurich
asz cache valley state il ne trouvera
pas maire nous a trouvés [ __ ] coûts et
aux as il m'envoie dans loïs qui vient
dans l'eau il a peur hein c'est sur un
os mais son point faible
ils sont pas les steaks lieu à l'escwa
[ __ ] de fouet et je suis ou ken loach
est comme ça
alors ça c'est donc logiquement voilà
notre avant terre un peu kraft et voilà
ça qui m'intéresse est ce que là par
exemple ça marche je saigne admet québec
scemama ça me fait saigner quoi nickel
et est-ce que je vais carrément faire
tomber l'arbre en temps pour être les
points non mais c'est scandaleux quoi
bon gars hockey hebdo qui disparaît en
plus le pet le point de sucre qui s'en
va et aucun souci en arrive à faire nuit
oh là là mais je vais crever mon gars
c'est sûr wad temps forts à choix que
j'ai des petits problèmes de connexion
mais vous avez vu combien de mois et un
requin qui volaient quoi nous faut de la
pierre ya pas de lapierre quelque part
en mode deviens joueurs là-bas hockey du
canadien lundi dont 8 ou quoi ils volent
les plantes
je vais le laisser tranquille il me fait
peur je crois que j'ai faim j'ai faim
j'ai froid je veux mourir ok quelqu'un
fait un peu juste laval on va on va voir
si on peut être copain avec lui là haut
je crois qu'il a f 15 mais j'ai pas
envie de tuer les gens mais qui m'aide
en fait
et vas-y f2p table où tu as fait tu
crois je t'ai pas vu mais je t'ai vu
pouce aux mondiaux on a accès à son
inventaire qu'est ce qu'il y avait sur
lui on prend tout on s'en va à l'essai
au [ __ ] je culpabilise ça se fait trop
parce que je me lavais de la bière aussi
ça se fait carrément il avait même un
truc sur le pour monter les dinosaures
il a une selle de dino il se relève or
en dortoir honneur toi on our temps
moyen de tuer ma part je me barre je me
marre franchement j'ai un truc à je suis
mort est allé on voit la lumière au bout
du tunnel alors on entend de mourir à
tanger ramasser du kakadu mincoy sur le
mec c'est n'importe quoi
oh non je suis mort j'ai pas le temps de
manger
on voudra survivants est-ce que tu as
donné ta pierre [ __ ] au bon dieu ok on
l'a défoncé il avait de la pierre je
bute faucheux but il encore vivant des
ced c'est bon t'es mort et grâce à eux
on pourra se faire une petite torche
l'atome est ce que j'ai fais caca et jeu
et je peux ramasser mon caca on s'en
fout ça ne sert plus urgent à sert à
rien au tournant la pioche
annick elle va pouvoir prendre delà de
la pierre en masse l'inde est un bon
feeling là je le sens après avoir tué
deux chauffeurs et les avoir dépouillées
on est bien on voit rien bordel il faut
vraiment une torche agents peu plus que
j'ai faim je suis déshydraté est ce
qu'on peut dire que ça sent le décès un
peu à la paillade la végétation c'est le
paradis là dans la danse / ya de quoi
faire la whey c'est quoi kraft et la
torche c'est génial maintenant qu'il
fait jour plus tu me fais trop laid je
ramasse plan b j'adore les b je suis je
suis belliard d'air là ça remonte un
tout petit peu à temps mais mec ça
remonte de canal quoi il faut que je
prenne six ans besson déconner mois
passé toute cette vidéo à manger
virtuellement c'est génial la prochaine
fois je vais une vidéo on est au kebab
serra plus vite en amont du regarder aux
mondiaux en habiller nos muscles des
jambes ne sont plus à la vue de tous
il ya un bruit de porte bien mais pas
loin bien avec valence ans il est où
et qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on attaque
ou pas mais c'est sa base il le bel 21
ne touche pas à te pique tb en poquets
non mais en fait ça c'est son chant
c'est sa culture ses terres ses
propriétaires de ce lieu banques et on
en train de voler toute la bouffe on
s'en fout il m'a vu il m'a vu il
gouverne ou je me bats au oui les
énormes attentes je vais le voir
non je vais mourir on le tente
voilà c'est passionnant mais je crois
que je vais juste agressés tous les
joueurs que je vois voilà le bel20 100
j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
on passe en mode et hervé un mode
frustration alors j'ai demandé comment
avoir de l'eau et on m'a dit qu'il faut
aller nager
voilà la rescousse fout de ma gueule
est-ce que je peux me faire attaquer par
le requin géant qu'on a vu au début on
voyait des pierres là sur la sur la
plage c'est beau ça et des coquillages
aussi une fois des pierres sur tous et
auquel on s'en fou tout ce qui est beau
il sert à rien on s'en fout ah c'est
vrai [ __ ] faut vraiment aller dans
l'eau pour boire quoi attendait juste
c'est la merde quoi en fait nos boîtes
ussel donc logiquement on s'hydrate pas
du tout est faux raccords à moi je suis
scandalisé c'est quoi ce dinosaure
ridicule luge péter fond c'est bel et
bien lui je vous dis un truc dès qu'on a
une arme ou le des fonds s'ils ont le
beauf ou le beauf attention à ces
[ __ ]
non je suis dans mon inventaire mais en
plus il va envenimer mais quelle conne à
un jour je serai un grand joueur de ce
jeu auquel assez the place to be ici
c'est parfait ya des arts de la pierre
il ya tout et il ya du caillou pour nous
on est bien on est bon on est bon on est
bon on va pas faire une gourde voilà
comme ça on pourra s'hydrater même qu'on
n'y aura pas d'eau juste à côté
c'est un train non level 27 qui me tue
mais t'as pas de vie mon gars tu toi je
te baise toi je te baise et le baseball
est là le pavage il avait ressenti au
fait tu vois le juger trop dessus de
nous lever lé 27 situe à level 3 t'as
pas honte je veux dire à tes enfants à
ta femme n'aura jamais j'avoue je suis
frustré je suis très frustré bon le truc
est cool quand même c'est que les
recettes que tu as a prises
même quand tu meurs tu t'en souviens
quoi défense quoi s'exposent ta gueule
barrez vous devez un [ __ ] à 3 v 1 je
me tire
je vous fais un rapide bilan des
situations mal connexion à bugger donc
j'ai rejoint notre serveur mais en fait
tu reprend tout à zéro quand tu vas tu
vas sur nos serveurs mais par contre tu
te la donne ce qu'on a fait la
découverte de ce2 se pousse un voile à
aller vers la paix à l'âme et de pâques
tumulte toi ça c'est faux on va le
prendre avec nous la met juste là il
tourne autour de nous on fait du hula
hoop
avec le deed il fait nul mais là on sent
ballester parce qu'on a une torche
[ __ ] qui est ce un spot quoi qui fait
lui passe par oew et il ya une sorte de
problème la main elle et moi en fait
hvm pas prendre au québec est juste
bogué quoi les bugs et andy reid fait du
limbo c'est tout dire qui est un mec pas
loin qui l'a buté quand même aux non non
mais laissez moi on fait bordel deux
joueurs aillent à la tanche i'm a
empoisonné non mais par toi t'as pas de
vie c'est bon j'ai largué je vais tester
ce petit étant très bien jeune âge à
deux à l'heure voilà j'ai plus
d'endurance où l'os et pare feu bah
ouais mais tu étouffes mais [ __ ] balle
célèbre mais l'écho mais il est
complètement con mais les capi leininger
sous luis nouaye quoi merci
bon et bien voilà les choses il ya pas
de cette idée sur ce pétales survival je
sois souza plus ces cas n'était pas aimé
la vidéo comme d'habitude c'était
désastreux voilà on a tout pouvoir et en
même temps c'est depuis dans la
connexion ne m'a pas vraiment idée mais
là mourir noyés parce que tu as plus
assez d'énergie pour nager faut voir ça
va vous n'hésitez pas à venir s'ils
voulaient une deuxième vidéo sur ce jeu
quand je me serai bien m'entraîner je
pense que ce sera un brin peu meilleure
mais la voilà c'était comment ne pas
survivre en milieu dinosaur esque mère
savoir regarder jazz all one piece